hello again you lovely folks letting you
know right out the gate this video is
brought to you by squarespace the
all-in-one platform to build your online
presence and run your business gonna
talk about that a little later but first
it's gonna be a long year in gotham
[Music]
batman the long halloween part one so
batman the long halloween is a long time
respected
classic and hailed graphic novel by jeff
loeb and tim sale
it's a weird flex even looking through
it now i just
love the tone of this graphic novel so
now we have a two-part
adaptation of the graphic novel in
animated film form
first of all the animation is great it's
top-notch and it works with the long
halloween there's a certain tone you
have to have when you're adapting the
long halloween and you have to have that
tone because whereas there are
batman villains in here and batman
characters that you know
for that batman flyer for the most part
it deals with the fact that there's this
unknown killer offing mobsters on
holidays that's
they know the killer as holiday the
holiday killer and i imagine there are
people out there who
haven't read the story they don't know
where the story is going to go but it's
also the
the birth of a very famous batman
villain it's a very long form
modern gothic noir investigative tone
you have to go for and i think this
animation does a really good job at
adapting that at first i was like it has
the tone of batman the animated series
if batman the animated series didn't
have danny elfman doing the score it has
the bow yeah it has the blouse the
blouse
when batman shows up just bow i thought
it worked they do have to take
some liberties in adapting the graphic
novel story
to an animated film like joker you look
at joker in the graphic novel he is
so exaggerated in his features you have
to take that
and put it in a world that works and
looks more human i thought they did a
really good job at taking that stylistic
joker form from the graphic novel and
turning him into a human that
still looks like that and pays respect
to that
but also works in here also catwoman's
costume is the more simplified sleek
black
version of catwoman's costume not the
purple suit with the big ears
and the tail i guess tails don't really
work when you're a cat burglar i thought
the voice acting was great in long
halloween too because the voice acting
is
well cast for what the characters have
to be jensen apples plays bruce wayne in
batman which is funny he plays red hood
in the red hood animation too which kind
of shows the fact that they're like hey
we want a younger
sounding bruce wayne which i mean he was
red hood 10 years ago
but still younger sounding bruce wayne
then kevin conroy cause at first i was
like oh i miss conroy because i'm always
gonna miss conroy when kevin conroy is
not the voice of batman
that's just how it's going to be forever
for me 101
on my deathbed i'm going to be like i
really miss conroy
this is how it's going to go down that
said once i got past
that jensen ackles really worked for the
younger batman they're clearly going for
in here like if they didn't establish
this supposed to be a younger batman
well the fact that harvey dent is harvey
dent
not harvey two phases it's you know it's
clearly younger batman but they go
through steps in here to establish no no
this is younger batman like the
batmobile doesn't have bulletproof
windshields yet a huge arc in here is
the fact that i mean
batman has to be a detective to figure
out what's going on and who this killer
is but there's this dialogue he has with
alfred where he's like
dude i just thought being batman i was
gonna scare some people
i didn't know i was going to have to be
a detective do you think any villains
named rachael ghoul are ever going to
know me as that name
maybe now which is funny because i'm
pretty sure the batman in long halloween
has been batman for longer than batman
in the dark night like the movie
but still in dark knight he's all like
fingerprints he's still doing his
detective work here
this is where he figures out i gotta do
that i gotta be that good at
that job i didn't know this was supposed
to be a hobby so i appreciate those
steps and there are moments in here that
i liked in the graphic novel that
are present in here i mean there are
some moments that aren't
they take some liberties like this one
scene where the house explodes
and they do a thing in here that's
supposed to be one of those
are they going that direction in here
they're kind of condensing the ah fool's
you
and that's why it exists that way we're
in the graphic novel it went down a
little differently
and for a fool jew moment it works but i
think for the long game when part two
comes out and you have the whole story
i think looking back it would have been
better to go the graphic novel route
that's just me and the reason i like the
voice acting in here is because the
voice acting is well cast to be people
who are
good people you know these are the
characters they are they're supposed to
be good but also same voice actors kind
of illustrate but do they have a secret
don't know i can't really be a lawyer
and a criminal can i
i want to win because as jamie kennedy
said about the long halloween
everybody's a suspect and the story
keeps you on your toes it keeps you
guessing you're like all right i have
suspects and
there are multiple suspects i have right
now you're looking at everybody you're
like
all right where were you last night
alfred you got secrets and you need
voice actors that illustrate that i
thought the voice acting was really well
cast troy baker plays joker in here
which troy baker
is the joker you get when you can't get
mark hamill to be the joker because
there are other voice actors that do
joker and they kind of make it their own
troy baker's joker is specifically the
mark hamill joker
there's only room for one homicidal
maniac in this town
i thought he was great in arkham origins
as that joker and i thought he was great
in the long halloween is that joker in a
world where we can't have kevin conroy
as the younger batman i'm glad we still
have the familiarity of a joker
that is very much like mark hamill's
joker i will say the passage of time
feels a little off and that's where
graphic novels have it
above any adaptation that can ever
happen when you reach the end of a
chapter or an issue that made up the
graphic novel
you can have this splice in time and it
feels natural like all right it's been
months that's fine because
there's that break in the chapters or i
finished an issue and now i'm on to the
next issue when it's a film adaptation
or animated adaptation you don't have
that
so you just kind of you're like okay so
they just said it was thanksgiving and
now i know that it's
been about a month didn't feel like a
month but now i know but that's a minor
cripe all in all the long halloween part
one i was thoroughly entertained i was
thoroughly locked in my biggest gripe is
the fact that when it ends you're like
yep
it ended and it kind of just i gotta
wait for part two now it's done it's
over and
why why is it broken up into two parts i
mean i would
i know why and it's not because time no
i don't want to sit through a three-hour
epic gothic investigative batman mystery
said no one ever they'd do it i would
we would all do it now the reason is
because instead of selling you one
three-hour batman story that they'll
charge 25 bucks for
they'll sell you part one and part two
at 20 bucks each 40 bucks and all
they're making a bit more money on it so
i mean logistically i get it but from
where i said it's kind of annoying that
i have to wait i guess i have the
graphic novel i can just
read it didn't that would be that
i'm totally gonna do that anyway it's so
good so in the end batman the long
halloween part one i thought it was
really good
great even it does the graphic novel
justice i don't have that fulfillment
and i won't until part two comes out but
if you're a fan of the long halloween or
you've never read the long halloween i
suggest you watch this and or read the
long halloween like if you watch part
one
you're just gonna end up reading long
halloween because you won't be able to
wait but it's a great batman story that
i'm glad they adapted to an animated
film and so far for part one
they did it really well and as i
mentioned before this video is brought
to you by squarespace squarespace sells
over 200 top level domains so you can
find the perfect name for your website
buying a domain from squarespace is
simple there are no hidden fees between
that and the fact that you can present
videos from youtube vimeo and animoto on
your squarespace site always good to not
have
to re-upload when you already have the
video elsewhere they're not messing
around when they say they are the
all-in-one hub to run your online
presence and not just presence no
empire i like that so click the link
below to go to squarespace.com
jeremyjohns to save 10 off of your
purchase of a website or domain using
promo code john's and thank you once
again to squarespace for sponsoring this
video
i do appreciate it all right so batman
the long halloween part one have you
seen it or have you read the graphic
novel of the long halloween in either
case what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you